okay
all right
i
welcome to a history of violence this
panel here
and i'd like to introduce the the
panelists and myself as the moderator my
name is leo brodie i'm the author of
this book i'll brandish everybody's
books so we have a nice object to look
at from chivalry to terrorism war and
the changing nature of masculinity which
goes from the middle ages up to the up
to the present and how masculinity and
interacts with war and both changing
their nature
uh this was published by originally by
kanoff and is now out in the vintage
paperback
to my right
is david bell david bell is mellon
professor of the humanities at johns
hopkins university and dean of the
faculty he's a contributing editor to
the new republic
teaches courses in european history and
the french revolution and he's also the
author of the cult of the nation in
france inventing nationalism 1680 to
1800 his new book is the first total war
napoleon's europe and the birth of
europe as we know it
published by hoot and mifflin recently
in paperback from mariner
scott martell writes for the la times
and is now covering the presidential
campaign his new book is blood passion
the ludlow massacre and class war in the
american west published by rutgers
university press
andrew nagorski is senior editor at
newsweek international where he's been
bureau chief in moscow berlin and
elsewhere his previous books include the
novel last stop vienna out from simon
schuster here is the greatest battle
stalin hitler and the desperate struggle
for moscow that changed the course of
world war ii and we hope that mark
kurlansky will join us because mark
kerlansky's book is you know in a sense
the the counter poise to the focus on
violence here his book is called
non-violence the history of a dangerous
idea
but let's begin uh
let's begin with david bell here uh
david could you just talking about your
book could you just talk to us a little
bit about what is total war how do you
define it and why do you date it
particularly from the napoleonic period
well thank you and thank you everybody
for coming
um
i think it's important to make clear
what a what total war is not it's not
simply destructive war it's not even
exterminatory war i think you can't
simply define total war in terms of what
you do to the enemy because you also
have to define it in terms of what total
war means for your own society
i think a total war
is a war in which a society tries to
mobilize its entire population and all
of its resources when everything is
directed to the war effort
now for this reason i think it's very
much a modern phenomenon
in pre-modern society so many people are
simply involved in providing food
providing resources for everybody else
that it's difficult even to conceive of
total war and you just don't have the
necessary level of social and political
organization
to make total war possible just to give
an example in the hundred years war
between britain and france in the middle
ages you certainly had a lot of vicious
fighting
but if fighting was going on for example
in northern france there wasn't really
any effort to bring the peasants of
southern france into the war effort that
kind of level of social and political
organization that attempt to turn people
away from their farming from the
necessary production of resources simply
wasn't conceivable
so what i argue is that total war first
really became possible actually at the
end of the 18th century
now you didn't you didn't actually see a
total mobilization of european nations
even even then and i would argue that in
fact
it's always something of an ideal if you
can use that word for something so
terrible it's not an ideal um you know
you can't actually reach it um but you
do see at least the first concerted
attempts to do it moreover you saw a
process taking shape in which the
combatants tried harder and harder to
get to this point of complete
mobilization until one side simply
collapsed you had a kind of unstoppable
radicalization of warfare and you can
see this even in the just in the size of
the armies and the battles
even at the start of the french
revolution in the 1790s battles rarely
had more than 30 40 50 000 men involved
um altogether but by the battle of
vagram which napoleon fought against
austria in 1809 you had 300 000 people
on the battlefield
by 1813 just four years later the battle
of leipzig you had five hundred thousand
people on the battlefield of whom 150
000 were killed or wounded now this
efforts couldn't be couldn't be
sustained ultimately france simply
collapsed despite unprecedented attempts
to mobilize the society and through
conscription through mobilization of
economic resources and so on and so
forth maybe i'll stop there and then i
can come back to the game later
let me just ask a follow-up question to
that
david that is what about the 17th
century what about the 30 years war i
mean the way the 30 years war certainly
inspired kyo and
observers to to think that this was like
war on a devastating scale that never
existed before
is there a difference let's say between
a kind of endemic war like that and a
total war
uh yes i think there is a very very big
difference the wars of the 17th century
were incredibly destructive
but the destruction was due mostly to
these marauding bands of soldiers the
kind of the seoul da tesca they were
called who would would ravage large
areas particularly of central europe but
but there wasn't you didn't have in any
of the contending nations an attempt to
mobilize the entire nations for war and
in that sense it's very similar to the
hundred years war if you had uh for
example the france which was one of the
participants in the hundred in the 30
years war
um
you didn't you didn't you know most of
france was not really even touched by it
the areas that were devastated that were
were treated very very badly you had
huge loss of population nonetheless you
didn't have this kind of total
mobilization of everybody in the society
which makes for a total war
scott martel uh your book focuses not on
total war but on the ludlow massacre in
colorado as a seemingly small scale kind
of situation uh
uh and in fact a a massacre a situation
that's to a great extent largely
forgotten uh what drew you to this topic
and why do you think it should be
remembered
well the thing that first drew me to it
um
i've known about the ludlow massacre for
a number of years i read dos pasos's usa
trilogy in my early twenties and just
kind of became enamored of that era
and through that and other readings
became familiar with ludlow massacre
which was the deaths of 11 children and
two mothers who suffocated when they
were hiding in an underground uh bunker
lack of a better word below a tent and a
striker's tent colony and national
guardsmen towards the colony and they
suffocated in the hole in the ground um
i knew about that incident i was reading
another book and there was a footnote
that made reference to a hundred people
who died in the the broader conflict in
which the massacre happened i thought
how the hell did i not know that you
know it's it's it's that's a lot of
bodies to die in american soil in pitch
you know warfare and local warfare how
did i not know that uh so i began poking
into it you know just out of a uh you
know ignorance how did i not know that
and there's a thin line between your
curiosity and obsession and it quickly
slipped over into obsession
but it's
it's one of those things that there's
this nation this culture has got a
tendency
to look at things large like big wars
big events big people and a lot of times
it's the small things that seem to
define us and this was
this was the sort of the last of the
very violent encounters between uh
management and labor after that
everybody sort of realized that the pr
losses were a lot higher than the body
losses and so things began to change
after they're still violent encounters
but but i think it's one of those events
it's crucial for us to remember
um yeah one of the union rallying calls
is you know the union is the people who
brought you the weekend and this is
these are the kinds of things that that
that people died over uh less than a
hundred years ago that we take for
granted we take for granted now yeah
it's like we're all here because it's
our day off and you know eight ninety
years ago people died fighting to have
this day off and to me that was just a
crucial thing to remember
welcome mark thank you
all right
uh touring the ucla campus in a golf
course
well we're glad you're here thank you uh
let me turn to andrew nagorski uh
it's a the war that you're writing about
the battle rather that you're writing
about is a is an enormous battle but
it's also forgotten uh in a way that um
that the ludlow massacre was forgotten
and want to bring it back into
historical consciousness could you talk
a little bit about that why you wanted
to do it yes well
i have to say sort of like scott i this
was a subject that
uh i wasn't immediately drawn to even
though i served twice as moscow bureau
chief for newsweek once in the soviet
era and once in in the 90s
and during that time
there was so much propaganda and
mythology about what was called the
great patriotic war world war ii
that i my feeling was
i don't really want to get into this too
much uh and there's a why should i ge
talk about something that has been so
uh is so in wrapped in ritual and and
and in mythology but then i began to
realize
this is the biggest battle of world war
ii
and let me just give you the very basics
it's when the germans invaded the soviet
union in 1941
in june 41 they then began their drive
in moscow in september 30th 1941. the
battle date is is dated till
april 42 so that makes about 200 days
seven million troops involved
of which two and a half million are lost
which means killed outright taken
prisoner which is basically
a death sentence on the other side or
severely wounded
and of those two and a half million
almost two million are on the soviet
side even though technically the soviets
won the battle because they just barely
held off the germans and say well why
does this get such short shrift in the
history books
and i think a big part of that is
there's a narrative in in russia
during soviet times and which is
unfortunately coming back in the putin
era which says stalin may have done some
nasty things but he was a great war
leader
and
in fact what i and the more i got into
this the more i realized that the level
of those casualties the fact that moscow
came as far as
as close to falling as it did and which
would have changed the war for everyone
not just for the soviet union but for
britain the united states everyone else
was a result of a series of blunders
that stalin made
and this goes against so so he can't
maintain stalin was a great war leader
and still tell the full story of the
battle moscow so that's that was my
motivation for for trying to tell that
and tell that story
mark kerlansky uh we all three the
panelists here perhaps four including
myself are dealing with with violence in
war
and with a kind of history of violence
and your book is about non-violence but
one of the points that you make
early on in your book is that
non-violence isn't passive that it's
active and positive and you want to
distinguish it from pacifism yeah
absolutely i mean it's it's a form of
of political activism
people like mohandas gandhi and martin
luther king were political activists
they were not interested no no word
would would more ill describe them than
passive
and it's
it's a it's a form of activism
that uh is is is based on the idea
that um
uh you can more effectively accomplish
things
uh
without all this carnage and bloodshed
and millions of lives and
um
and i wrote the book because
uh
history
tends not to tell this story
um history tells the story of one war
after another and the great war leaders
a great leader wouldn't be at war
um
and uh i i don't think anything better
uh
clarifies uh why i thought this book was
necessary than the fact
that uh i've looked in
every language in the world i can find
no
proactive word for non-violence
it's always
non-violence you know the negation of
violence now suppose you imagine a world
in which there was a word for
non-violence but there was no word for
violence except non
this other word
now you'd think well that would be a
world uh
in which uh
behaving non-violently was normal and
behaving violently with an aberration
i'd like to live in that world but uh
i don't
david bell let me
turn this to you what do you think has
changed in warfare and in the idea of
the state that allowed total war to
happen
well this actually follows surprisingly
on what mark just said because in fact
one thing that it followed on was a
certain idea of non-violence because i
think that it's sometimes the case that
people who believe in non-violence or
who believe in pacifism can actually be
pushed towards violence and towards war
let me let me explain what i mean by
that the people who began the wars that
i write about these are the french
revolutionary napoleonic wars the people
france declared war in 1792 in the midst
of its revolution now just two years
before
the same people in france had had
had issued a decree saying that france
would actually never go to war unless it
was provoked because they believed that
they were on the edge of an era of
perpetual peace
and this is coming out of the the many
of the beliefs of the enlightenment
where they really where people were
beginning to feel that for the first
time they might be able to define peace
as the ordinary condition of mankind
that maybe people would no longer have
to fight anymore certainly wars in the
period were growing considerably um less
violent at that time people were
beginning for the first time to think
that to define war or something
primitive or something anachronistic is
something you didn't have to do
but then you had these people who really
believed this who were in charge of the
country
um and they came to believe that well
the trouble was the people on the other
side of the border weren't agreeing with
them so they came to think well maybe we
should simply have one final war one
last war one war to end all war so to
speak that if we could just do this if
we could wipe the slate clean then we
could finally have perpetual peace and
so they declared war and began 23 years
of absolutely hideous carnage so it's
one of the paradoxes i think of pacifism
and of non-violence that unless you
define it absolutely rigorously to say
that under no conditions will you go to
war even when provoked that it can
actually provoke greater violence
well one of the things that happened
with the napoleonic wars was to excite
nationalist feelings in countries that
otherwise didn't have them or they were
quite submerged before that so i mean is
that kind of new that
19th century nationalism then a crucial
factor in this
well i think that
nationalism in part
arose in reaction to
uh the french conquest during the war i
mean this was a period when france
established the greatest empire that had
been seen
in europe really since even not even
since the time of charlemagne but since
the time of the caesars every single
state in europe saw its political system
or saw its borders changed significantly
over this period from 1792 to 1815 and
you had this french empire that extended
like this huge ink plot over almost the
entire map of europe so this did provoke
in a lot of countries nationalist
reactions against the french occupiers i
think in most cases at the time the
reaction tended to be limited above all
to the social elites for example in
germany you had a lot of talk about a
lot of patriotic talk about defending
and even unifying the fatherland at this
time germany was not yet of course
unified in this period um but these were
movements that really came to fruition
about 70 80 years later for the most for
the most part a little earlier in italy
70 80 years later in germany
uh scott martel
again with the ludlow massacre we're in
a situation
uh where it's as you were saying it's
labor versus management in some sense
they're in the federal government
doesn't intervene until almost the very
end of it what's the what do you see is
the the whole question of violence there
that i mean there's violence between
these two groups between the strikers
and the and the owners and then and the
government sort of has a hands-off
feeling uh tendency for most of it well
the federal government the state
government got involved pretty early on
by sitting in the national guard uh
which quickly became co-opted by the the
mine operators um but in a lot of ways i
i didn't think about this as i was
writing it listening to you guys talk in
a lot of ways it was almost a stateless
war you know it was the workers against
you know the capital as sort of a
classic marxist analysis you know
workers against capital
um but the violence began
elsewhere in other labor management
encounters uh pink creek west virginia
several months earlier
some of the same organizers and some of
the same um
baldwin felt detectives who were
involved in the company side uh were
involved in west virginia and they moved
up to colorado so a lot of ways it was
the same transportable players you know
into another template where this this
confrontation comes up and just the
terms of engagement from the get-go was
violence
now this this occurs in
1913-1914 i mean do you have any sense
let's say that somehow
world war one and what was happening on
a global scale sort of siphoned off the
violence here and
redirected it in some way no not at all
i think what it did is it siphoned off
our kind of collective memory of this
you know um
america is a culture we tend to
to my view anyway we tend to look at
american history in terms of pre-world
war one which is like old history and
post-world war one
and this happened obviously before world
war one and it kind of got everybody's
attention elsewhere
it's also
labor history and we tend to ignore
labor history
and it also happened in the west and we
tend to ignore history in the west you
know it tends to be dominated and driven
by by an eastern perspective i think all
three of those together kind of
conspired to sort of keep this well of
course after world war one there's a
kind of reaction against immigrants and
radicals as well after the war is over
right but that was a play here because
most of the miners were immigrants in
fact the the coal operators had been a
pretty nasty strike in 1903 and the
unions were broken then and the coal
operators replaced all of the mine
workers with immigrants and they went
for as broad a base as they could i
forget exactly something like 17
languages were spoken on the mines the
reason for that is awfully hard to
organize a union when the workers can't
talk to each other so it was by design
they were bringing in these people but
when the strike itself began 1913 uh the
management was looking at these guys as
as
you know ignorant riffraff you know
coming in uh not intending to be
americans just trying to take the money
and send it home and go back
so that whole nativism thing you know
came into play but but
i think that part of the problem here in
terms of history is that we tend to look
at history as
going from war to war and then the
incidental material in between
[Music]
i think that's true
but there's there's certainly there's
some kind of compelling parallels i
would ask andrew nagorski
here let's say with that napoleonic uh
precedent in mind do you think that it's
kind of hitler and stalin
in this situation were both kind of
napoleon wannabes and
well those those analogies are
fascinating i i think first of all an
answer to your question about
what was different in terms of this war
and why we could have a battle on this
scope with these many casualties
is that these political systems before
the war were based on violence
totalitarian systems which are pioneered
in the soviet union then later in nazi
germany were based on that violence 1937
1938 stalin has the purges where
approximately 750 000 people are just
shot
including the top military brass
so his army is totally unprepared
and of course everyone is terrified of
him we know everyone in in germany is
terrified of hitler and so in that
system there's no accountability
you cannot er
and it means that the tyrants are free
to make whatever mistakes they want and
what in effect what you have is
happening
is these two tyrants outdoing each other
in their stupidity
uh you know
you have this this sort of contest do
you have hitler who invades the soviet
union
in june
20 june 21 19 1941
which is
to the day 129 years after napoleon
marches into this into russia you think
that might give him pause
and he sends his troops in without
winner uniforms because victory will be
assured before the winner comes and
comes which of course it doesn't
you have stalin who for all sorts of
reasons doesn't believe all the reports
that hitler is going to go going to
going to uh invade
as a total paranoid person if everybody
is his own spies and the west are
telling him that he's going to be
invaded it must be a plot
and he does so he doesn't allow his
troops to be ready they get overrun
weapons caches get overrun and he ends
up sending troops out into the field
without weapons
in many cases you'd have or only a few
weapons and and if you were a soldier
without a weapon you were supposed to
try to survive long enough to pick up
somebody's weapon
and that's only possible in systems that
say
human human
lives don't count and enormous amounts
of manpower yeah and waste yeah in fact
stalin during the korean war told
premier zhou and lai the chinese premier
he said well have the north koreans
sending as many troops against the
americans as possible
because they have nothing to lose but
their men
and hitler's hitler's attitude was
exactly the same thing he saw it as a
sign of weakness if his generals tried
to limit their casualties well there's
the story from world war ii of
eisenhower and marshall zhukov talking
about various matters as the war was
coming to conclusion and eisenhower
trying to impress yukov by talking about
the various ways that the
americans had devised for clearing
minefields and then he asked zhukov well
how do you clear a minefield and zhukov
replied oh we marched the infantry
across it
right right all right uh mark kurlansky
i wondered if if a total war at least in
in the way that david bell's defined it
does this generate ideas of total peace
in your book you start you started with
many of the forerunners of non-violence
and buddhism and
quakerism and other religions there but
for my reading i think you know the
non-violent movement i think you make
this point also really gets going much
more in the 19th century so i mean is
that also a response to napoleonic
warfare
well
uh i mean there was that response to the
napoleonic wars i mean there was there
was a huge peace movement following the
the napoleonic wars and actually
one of the things that it gave birth to
was the idea of a european union
um
uh i i don't completely agree that it it
it didn't really get going till the 19th
century throughout history i mean if you
just look at the early christians the
first
250 years of christianity was was one of
the most
uh determined uh peace cults in in
history people who would not even
participate in governments because
government was violent
it it has always been there
it has always been
a huge debate within
the major religions
um and uh i think that
what changed a bit
uh i i think that gandhi
changed things quite a bit
uh
because he was so good at it
and he kind of wrote the manual for how
to do it
and uh most non-violent movements of
which there have been a lot
since gandhi have studied gandhi uh
the civil rights movement was based on
studying gandhi and
the uh
after the soviet invasion of
czechoslovakia uh the czechs started
studying gandhi and uh
um
uh
it um
it was this it was this example um
that uh
that made a huge impression and greatly
advanced the uh the techniques of
non-violence of course modern
non-violence is much more based on media
than it used to be it is all
all about i mean the civil rights
movement was all about how do we get
this on television the whole world is
watching yes
i just wanted to say i i agree with that
and entirely i think one interesting
thing about the history of sort of
christian non-violence christian
pacifism is that
christians also have and have
traditionally had such a strong sense of
original sin
so that while you
preach pacifism you preach non-violence
it comes together with a kind of deep
conviction that we can never actually do
it that we're too bad to do it that
we're too corrupt to it so i think one
of the interesting things in history is
when you start having a kind of secular
pacifism a secular non-violence which is
grounded in sort of a theory of history
that says violence is primitive and we
can get beyond it by evolving yeah i
mean that's
personally that was an interesting thing
because uh i was drafted into the
vietnam war
and i refused to go i told him i wasn't
going to go and they said okay well then
you're a conscientious objector so you
have a
hearing on your conscientious objector
and and i discovered that
they did not recognize a secular
conscientious objector so i spent a lot
of times grilling grilling rabbis on on
how to show that judaism was a peace
cult and
well this this i wonder if this is one
way perhaps at the 19th century version
it does change that it gets more
secularized that that the earlier
history of non-violence is really inside
of absolutely specific religions and
that somehow i was thinking also the
kinds of things that happened in the
19th century like the founding of the
red cross by do not when he saw the
carnage of the battle of sofarino and
and florence nightingale clara barton i
mean there's there's a kind of movement
to to somehow
look at the battlefield in a different
way and and not to use the the sanction
of religion but to talk about talk about
violence per se well i i i think and you
know people may think this is absolutely
crazy of me but i i do think that in a
very slow and gradual way that people
are questioning war more and more i i
think of how much more acceptable it was
for me to refuse to fight in vietnam
than people i know who refused to fight
in world war ii
and how much
more acceptable rejecting the iraq war
is than uh rejecting vietnam war was the
the
the most unpopular the vietnam war ever
got was just barely over 50 percent
about 52 which is where the iraq war
started
um so
there is reason to hope that that people
are
catching on to this idea that we don't
have to
lay waste to a significant part of every
generation
scott martel i mean in terms of like
labor capital
violence too i mean that has certainly
changed i mean that's a kind of cultural
change and attitudes about how to solve
these kinds of problems that may be
that may be relevant to the
international stage as well yeah just
thinking as marcus talking
i'm wondering if what the difference is
like in the case of ludlow and the coal
miners they felt like they were fighting
for their livelihoods and they were
fighting almost a revolution to
overthrow a corrupt political system
economic system
and i'm wondering if the mindset's
different when you're fighting you know
the people in that valley over there
who've been screwing with you for the
past you know two years when it's you
know your government that everybody's
growing increasingly cynical about
telling you to go overseas and fight
people you never heard of before i'm
just wondering
well
it is always if you look through history
one of the
standard ways in which government
convince people to go to war is first
you have to convince people that those
other people are another and they're not
like us and they're less human
it's it's very frightening to me to see
the effort
uh that's going on right now in this
country to convince us that iranians are
less than human so that it will be okay
to kill them this is a process you see
as a prelude to every war
i was just going to say that first of
all i think a couple of stipulations on
non-violence and the evolution
first of all in in the totalitarian
facing say hitler our stalinist system
of course there is no option of
non-violence in the sense that
before you respond to that let me give
you uh if you let us say
you're called up for the red army you'll
be among the 158 000 people who were
shot for soldiers shot for desertion or
are are you know there was no discussion
of conscientious objection
uh or 22 000 and the germans so i mean
if you want to give your life fine but
beyond that and i would say i covered
for newsweek the non-violent movie
movements in the 80s which you referred
to like charter 77 in czechoslovakia
solidarity in poland
uh and you know we
had many discussions about this with
people like uh lectures uh uh uh uh anna
meekney watsonville
and there was also a very practical
consideration there it wasn't simply an
ideology of non-violence i would say the
practical consideration was we've had
violent uprisings in eastern europe
they cannot work against a system that's
willing to use tanks
against us so therefore
we will try to shame this system
and and break it but they really didn't
have a sense we're going to necessarily
break it javo had this wonderful
statement if you begin to calculate the
cost to me
of defying this system i'll never do
anything so i gotta i've got to do
something but they also knew this was no
longer the stalinist system
and they would not have worked against
the stalinist sister and against the
hillary and they were not pacifists by
nature this was a tactic a very
practical tactic and in some cases it
works and in the media is a key in this
case not because of their own media
because
western correspondents could get in
radio for europe bbc could broadcast
back uh reports on what was happening
that that official but in a closed
system none of that exists but you see
it it always is a tactic and a practical
tactic
gandhi was a very pragmatic man he had a
goal and he asked himself what do we
have to do to achieve this goal and
people often say well you know
non-violence is is fine against nice
people but you know if you've got really
brutal people uh
what can you do if people are really
brutal then your only not option is
non-violence which was exactly
what they uh concluded in in in in
central europe well if
you know if they have all the guns and
they have all the power the the only
option is non-violence well the uh the
option in the 30s for say many people in
in britain were saying there was a
strong pacific movement we cannot defy
hitler because and we don't want to go
to war which was understandable in terms
of an impulse i think it was completely
wrong politically
well part of part of the reasoning and
the oxford peace pledge and those kinds
of things was the
i mean hitler's response to that was
that this was you know not masculine
this was a you know this was going to be
the reason that germany was going to be
defeated not you know and put in this
whole idea of a of a kind of sense of
the country as a as a masculine
structure that has a sense of honor
which is somehow analogous to the sense
of individual honor that britain would
be defeated that britain would be
defeated because yeah britain and the
united states uh and you know in the
united states because of its what he
called its mongrel population that it
was not pure blooded right uh and so
because it's not pure-blooded it uh you
know it will be defeated because you
need pure blood to be truly masculine
the problem with with nazi germany was
that there were too few people who were
opposed to it who had all these people
like churchill who were focused on the
communists and and weren't really that
interested in you know uh uh britain and
the united states were selling arms like
crazy to europe there to germany they
were helping the the
the german economy they had no interest
in in in helping the jews
uh and you know that that was the story
of the 1930s
the the the people
the peace people were saying you have to
do more to resist the nazis and
if they had been able to get the floor
if if people had listened to them uh
they might have defeated nazis without a
war yeah so but the soviet side was the
car it was supplying hitler in during
the molotov ribbon draft pack not the
west no but the west was also scotland
to jump in here yeah i'm just wondering
uh more abstractly can
a tactic work without a moment of
vulnerability by the the dominant force
um
you know you talk about nazi germany if
you take a pacifist stance internally
against the nazis you're dead and you
know the next pacifist comes up i'm
wondering if sort of gandhi's
revelation is that you need to pick your
spot pick your moment and then have that
pacifism build to to a point of success
i mean you need that opening
i mean i think
non-violence because it is a tactic what
kind of tactic is it in a large sense
that in a large sense it's a kind of
tactic of publicity which means you need
people who are going to listen to you
you need people who are going to pay
attention to it if you don't have that
it can't work but you need an
institution that's vulnerable at the
moment otherwise they just shrug it off
well
if you don't have that publicity though
i mean you have you have you have like
the white rose movement in in hitler
germany uh you know and you have of
course the soldiers plot and things like
that and these were all
focus i mean it's like too idealized
there there was no i mean the kind of
things that happened with the civil
rights movement and with gandhi the
sense of of a publicity around that so
that would leverage those individual
acts into something larger
i mean nazi germany was very concerned
about their public image in the world uh
most most governments no matter how
horrible they are are are trying to make
themselves look okay to the world and
that's you know that's that that's
uh that's where the leverage is well
that's why i don't know
where they ever where did the nazis ever
change their policies because of the
their public image well
where were these strengths when were
they ever pressured to no but teresians
thought as an example after all they
wanted to show exactly show to the red
cross and you know an international
opinion that the jews were being taken
care of
and they certainly wanted yeah well
exactly
[Laughter]
i think it's time to open up the panel
to questions from the audience um
yes
i think
uh with women entering the military and
israel united states and other countries
will this change the nature of war
and if so will be for the better or
worse the question is with women
entering the military in israel and the
united states and other countries will
this change the nature of war for the
better or the worse
anyone like to feel that well one
interesting thing is that women have
actually always been involved in warfare
to a far greater extent than most even
most military historians realize i mean
if you go back for example to france in
the area that i look at um you had
hundreds of women who actually enrolled
in the french armies in masculine
uniforms some were they some were
discovered to be women and were allowed
to continue fighting got pensions
afterwards the armies of the period
generally had you know as much as a as
much as a third of the total population
going along with the armies was often
female it was they were not simply the
camp followers of legend but they were
doing everything from
from cooking to even digging ditches to
being support people so women have often
of course have always been involved in
war's victims but they were also being
involved in war
as
support personnel and even as
and even as combatants well i'm not sure
what we have is really quite something
in middle ages of course too i mean
there are many statements out that the
most dreaded thing about warfare was me
lying there wounded on the battlefield
the woman's going to come along and hit
you over the head with a mallet or
something like that because this is
exactly i mean the women would clean up
after the battles
on the soviet side in the battle for
moscow there were women were deployed in
anti-aircraft units and so they took
they were manning some of these
batteries and these searchlights which
were set up to try to capture
the flights coming in over moscow and
then and then set them up to be shot
down uh and they suffered casualties
because of that and then later on
there's some soviet women pilots as well
of course and they were not women combat
troops generally but there were
certainly women later on when they were
resistance units well and really your
question is about whether
a feminine sensibility is somehow going
to change warfare and whether there is
such a thing
and even if there is such a thing
whether it would have any scope
uh in that kind of warfare and i think
that's that's one of those kinds of
almost biological questions very hard to
decide because in fact as we've been
saying in many many of these you know
historically women have certainly i mean
it's a tribe there's a tribal thing as
well i mean women are supporting the men
who are fighting uh in these kind of
situations and whether whether their
participation will actually ameliorate
the violence is another question just to
throw to bring out to the the small war
level uh among the coal miners women
were very active uh there's no evidence
that i saw that they were actually
picking up rifles to fire but they were
certainly loading them and the biggest
sword on the side of the national guard
and the mine operators was mother jones
uh who was this you know demure
grandmother looking woman in her early
80s at that point and she was such an
instigator in the field that they threw
her in prison twice and tried to keep
removing her from the field she kept
coming back and you know i mean she was
you know she was the physical
manifestation of motherhood and
grandmotherhood and she's sworn like a
truck driver trying to fire up these
strikers to you know take on the
operators another question yes
um i think a number of you've been
skirting on this and uh there's a new
book out about world war ii
the idea of the good war on a couple of
questions about that one is is that a
new concept or was i mean was world war
ii specifically
um it's a
broke pattern or whatever was that and
second of all do you think that is
breaking down in any way that idea of
the quote good war the question is
whether the term good war which is so
frequently used to describe world war ii
uh was invented for world war ii whether
it has a history and whether it still
has any validity well you know it comes
out of the phrase just war which goes
back to uh the early early middle ages
saint augustine
and uh my take on that is that you know
the the the catholic church had a real
problem because the catholic church was
interested in getting into warfare in a
very big way
and they were supposed to be founded on
jesus who
was not into warfare in any kind of way
um and so there had to be some sort of
theological reckoning of this and so uh
augustine came up with this
this theory of the just war that you
know
certain a certain war certain causes
were just so just that they
justified in effect going beyond the
teachers you teach contradicting the
teachings of jesus and going out and and
killing it because it was in this
particular case just well you know what
i don't think in history there has ever
been anyone who pursued a war without
claiming it was just
that doesn't mean i don't think that
there weren't just wars i mean i think
there is
my father was in the polish army in 1939
uh uh being in
when germany invaded
in his mind there was no question that
this he was fighting a just war against
most people
and and i would say looking back he was
absolutely right or you agree with him
well but by the same by the same token
by the same token
their actions justified but we still
need some system to judge which actions
are criminal and which actions are not
is it not the same thing for wars i was
i was recently at a conference at the
world war ii museum in in new orleans
and somebody made the distinction there
not between it was talking about the
good war he said he didn't want to call
it the good war he wanted to call it the
necessary war that is to give a
pragmatic reason for it rather than a
moral reason
yeah david i i think a lot would be
gained by uh an attempt to do much more
to codify international law and you know
when the when the iraq war first broke
out i attended this conference at
columbia university law school in which
all of these legal scholars debated the
legality of the war
and what i found
is that international law is so vague on
this i mean it's a lawyer's dream you
can argue absolutely anything
yeah i would just argue that you know
any war you win is probably a good war
right
well i i would just also
i would also want to remind us i mean go
back to saint augustine uh that in fact
what he started talking about was the
fact that the uh the the
savage tribes the vandals they had
invaded rome and it was a question about
whether the nuns should submit to being
raped and killed this could have started
things out or whether they should resist
or not so i mean originally and then
this gets expanded into the idea of the
just war so originally it was about an
individual response and then it somehow
turned into a justification for a
cultural or social response because the
question is never really whether you
should resist or not you should always
resist the question is how you resist
another question yes
mark i look forward to reading your book
i have not read it yet
but i wonder if you could draw a
distinction that seems to be coming up
in the discussion but the distinction
between
a gandhi approach of saying
non-violence because then the person
perpetrating the violence on you will be
forced to confront the evil within
themselves
on the one hand versus a very practical
uh non-violent approach aimed at media
attention which could just be that the
person perpetrating the violence is
afraid that somebody bigger and stronger
is going to see that and come stop them
well i mean it's both of those things
and it's some other things also about
human nature about you know the fact
that we are
uh biologically
built to um uh respond to an attack we
have no built-in biological defense
against kindness
[Music]
it's a it it's a theory that's based on
many different things but but
certainly
an important component of it is the is
the reality that um
uh
if you are uh brutalizing unarmed people
and the world is watching you do it this
is not going to be good for
you yes
but before the
war
the germans started their experiments on
seeing how the german population would
respond to death camps by killing all of
the many and firms and all people in
their
san antonio until
a couple of church people stood up and
said this is wrong and the germans
stopped and so i think
they didn't march in the streets they
didn't
but they said in in heard just about
germany i think
some catholic and some protestant
said this is wrong and the germans
stopped so they were um you know
very very very other examples also
late in the war when the germans wanted
to deport to concentration camps uh
berlin jews that were in mixed marriages
berliners objected to it vociferously
and and they backed down there were also
people survived the war not very many
right yeah and there were also different
standards within germany and within
german occupied territories very
different and this was early that's the
early in the war when
when when this and then when there was
resistance to to killing
killing the the mentally disabled are
physically disabled but
later on it was done in quiet and
quietly without any resistance and and
uh certainly within in eastern europe
there
there were no breaks on any of this
yes
um could one of you are certainly you'll
also speak to internal wars like we've
seen
recently in kenya and then in sudan
first with the south and now with darfur
and i'd also like to hear about um the
concept of masculinity and its
relationship to war which we haven't
heard about yet thank you
internal wars
tribal wars wars within countries well i
mean in a certain sense scott yeah
that's what your book's about yeah it
kind of goes to the whole stateless
application but again you're talking
about
we were talking before about uh for wars
to begin and for citizenry to get
engaged you have to perceive the enemy
as another as the other
and i think that you know these you know
inter-state wars it's pretty much that
same kind of thing it's you know one
group for x reason decides that it's
going to go on the attack and usually
it's against somebody who's been
demonized a group of people have been
demonized and in the case like of the
coal miners
it was begun by the coal operators and
they had demonized the miners as you
know the immigrant riff raff and all
this kind of stuff
um and that was a justification for them
to you know violently push them out of
out of their their livelihoods i wonder
about the tribal side too and andy
perhaps you can address this i mean i
think during the um uh the
war in world war ii when after hitler
invaded russia wasn't there a great
revival of a lot of religiosity and
mother russia kind of language uh that
that otherwise stalin and the communist
party had had pushed to one side but
this was one of the few ways that they
had to kind of create a sense of
solidarity yes well one of the things
stalin was particularly always worried
about
was would he was would his people be
loyal
and one of the things i go into in great
detail in the book is how when the
germans invaded at first
many people and not just ukrainians or
balts or others there are other other
groups even some russians
uh and i got this from
from the secret police files where there
were transcripts of letters that were
that were captured by the censors were
saying the germans are invading this guy
hitler we don't know much about him
i'm loosely paraphrasing uh but it's
life has been a horror under under this
system under stalin he's killed so many
of us maybe these new guys will be
better
uh and that was the initial initial
feeling of some people before they
really saw what hitler was up to then of
course hitler comes in and immediately
says you know it doesn't work with that
he
he he says all these people need to be
enslaved or executed or
you know just dispensed with and of
course then then
then even people who are wavering in
their loyalty to whether you call it the
nation the tribe or whatever
rally because they see
their if they if they if they welcome
the newcomers they'll be they'll be
they'll get a bullet in return
so so it's you know you can't play that
but but hitler totally misplayed that i
think and to just respond to the second
part of your question about about
masculinity too i mean it's of course an
issue with an issue that that i'm
particularly interested in in my book
but i mean one of the problems of
talking about masculinity in
relationship to war is how you know
uh in the actually starting to be a
revival now but certainly in the in the
50s and 60s you had a lot of arguments
in the in the after world war ii that
and somehow this was instinctual the
urge the violence was instinctual
particularly for men uh and that uh
conrad lorenz certainly one of this and
uh robert ardry's african genesis also
deals with this kind of question
uh but you know how do you get from what
is considered to be an instinct let's
say to personal behavior the kind of
modifications that you do with your
personal behavior and then from personal
behavior to social behavior to
wars of aggression to politics i mean
there's so many steps along the way that
to talk about the talk about mere
instincts you know seems to reduce the
kind of complexity that that really
exists in this i mean it doesn't tell
you anything about what the difference
between the war in europe and the war in
the pacific was let's say in terms of
world war ii so i mean it's it's it's a
problem there i mean i think certain
kinds of things
like like the code of honor let's say
certain kinds of social constructions
which are connected to masculinity
obviously have a role to play in this
but this comes back i think also to the
question of international law the
problem of society is always about
overcoming people's instincts overcoming
people's drives making them being able
to live together when you have a society
formed you can have an overall authority
which can which can create law and
create the sense of constraints
necessary for people to obey the law and
then to help people internalize these
norms the trouble is when you look at
the international scene where is that
overall authority which is going to be
which is going to judge which wars are
correct which actions of a state are
criminal this is where the problem we do
have some agreements but they are
reciprocal agreements you don't have a
single international authority acting
the way our own
legal legal judicial system acts that
makes it very difficult i think part of
it also is
the question was about masculinity
human beings are instinctually inclined
to violence and particularly men are
instinctually confined to violence and
therefore war can never be eradicated
because of this this sense of
masculinity
well i i just think
that's such a bogus argument even if you
accept and biologists debate it but
let's just accept for a moment the idea
that it is it is instinctive um
uh
the whole idea of civilization is that
we can do better we can make ourselves
better uh
um you know wearing clothes is
completely unnatural but i don't see a
lot of people objecting to it
magnus throughout here a lot of this has
to do i think with cultural
self-identification
um
you know here in america you know kids
in the middle school playgrounds get
into altercations and a lot of times
it's shrouded in issues of masculinity
who's tougher you know and it's it's
almost like like in a cultural
relationship whatever that word is issue
for for young men in the society and i
go back to when the strikes were
beginning in southern colorado
mother jones one of her big uh hot
buttons that she was pushing when she
was trying to to radicalize the coal
miners she had this big speech in the
west theater and trinidad in front of a
couple of thousand coal miners and she
just hounded them and called them out in
their masculinity saying if you guys
aren't men enough to take on these
bosses who are ruining your lives then
get out of the way and let the women do
it you know so so even you know it's
used as a as a rallying point
i was amazed by this this thing that
occurred in the bush administration
where they started referring to the idea
of
getting out of iraq as cutting and
running are you going to cut and run
well the answer is yes
yes one more question yeah
again for the second time and i'm just
wondering has anybody seen the
correlation um
in the from the last eight years of the
bush administration
of 1984 i mean do you think that they
actually deliberately or by accident
kind of
start doing 1984
i mean that's where they got their ideas
[Laughter]
that was the playbook
i think politicians
i think politicians have lied and been
deceptive throughout history there's
there's there is a distinction between a
kind of totalitarian system which we are
not in i mean we can be here today and
have somebody like mark denouncing the
bush administration if this were 1984 we
would have the thought police coming in
and arresting him i hope that's not
going to happen on c-state
yeah i think
i think one has to be very careful about
analogies i think
david's point about the difference
between a totalitarian system and a
system where you may not like what your
government is doing you may say they're
lying but you have every right to say
that there's also something in the
nature of war that's different and
that's i think worth since we're talking
about violence and in the history of
violence
these
whatever one thinks of the iraq war
there's no question that the leadership
is it wants to keep casualties to a
minimum
that it that it is it is is trying to
trying to get out of this war however
however
you know
bumbling you can say it is
while in totalitarian systems
casualties are as high as high as you
want them to be it doesn't matter and
you can cover everything up so that
that's a fundamental difference i think
we have to acknowledge what that doesn't
mean you have to endorse any of the
policies but but there are differences
in the way our societies functions which
are which are quite fundamental and and
yeah
and
whether the casualty's low on our side
all right we're going to
i think we're going to have to yeah
we're going to have to continue uh some
of this afterwards but let me we can
just we're being a little reductive here
when we're talking about masculinity and
instincts and things like that but let
me let me be slightly more reductive
just to kind of wind things up and ask
the panel
uh you know from just from your
different points of view i mean is there
can you say that is there one crucial
factor that shapes the urge to violence
whether that urges in individuals or in
nations or cultures
okay i'll start i mean i would say
first of all i would you know scott
scott made the point that every country
that wins the war believes this one's
it's a just war and that's true
but i think we are evolving in terms of
looking at
history and some societies are doing
this better than others look at germany
it has looked at its history very
honestly and says what that war and what
hitler did in our name
is
a horror
russia has not gone through a similar
thing some people have attempted to do
it
but but the overwhelming sentiment has
been in the other direction that's very
important i think
there's a reason why world war one
people look back at it they don't have
the feeling that was really a just war
it's so messy so complicated so many
people dying and and who was right and
who was wrong on in starting that war is
far from clear
world war ii i think is quite different
and whether you call it just war or
necessary war i think a lot of people
would say that one
for
was necessary or just whatever you want
to want to call it so i think how you
face history it's an evolution i don't
think any international structure is
going to get us
provide us with all the answers but
facing honestly your history and trying
to write it honestly is important as
opposed to writing it for purely
political reasons in russia there's a
saying
how can you tell the future in a country
with an unpredictable past
because history gets rewritten so often
for overtly political reasons so if you
can try
to write history honestly and there are
people in russia today doing it and i
was able to benefit from that in the
book
uh and and and this applies in any
country and face it more honestly then i
think you have a chance of at least
evolving in a more constructive
direction and there's another parallel
with 1984 don't drop everything down the
memory hole
which seems to be a good point to end a
panel dealing with history thanks very
much for coming
if you would like to have your book
signed at
the north signing area
when you exit
at the rear and i'm asking that if you'd
like to communicate with any of these
and you are watching live coverage of
book tv's los angeles times festival of
books here on the campus of ucla that
panel on
has just ended and a little later on
we're going to have a panel on the 20th
century that'll be coming up
but right now we are joined on the
c-span bus by dr